how's the old ball and chain yeah dude  that's why I got married just so I could  do that you're like I didn't use this  hand that's true that ring on now yeah  dude how's it feel a little tight yeah I  have to say a wedding is pretty sick  it hits harder than you think okay I'm  about to cry now lock in dude oh yeah I  mean I cried like a baby when I propose  it's gonna that times five thousand  actually can I tell you at my friend's  wedding the moment I cried when everyone  sat down to eat the cake  yeah when the cake was all gone I was  last in line for cake and they're like  oh man the last piece we just delivered  we just gave it out  you just do the Milton from Office Space  they have to burn the wedding down  the burn down the building because  there's no cake for me